newly revealed documents show the Trump
administration took money away from FEMA
and other federal agencies apparently to
pay for immigration detention centers
FEMA lost nearly 10 million dollars out
of its 15 billion dollar budget Jeff
Pegues is in Washington with the
agency's response Jeff good morning good
morning over the last year there have
been questions about whether FEMA's
resources are stretched thin as it
responds to hurricanes and that's why
that nearly 10 million dollars is
getting a lot of attention this morning
the budget documents were first made
public by Senator Jeff Merkley a
Democrat from Oregon he is called the
money transfer a scandal more than 4
million dollars of the funds from FEMA
are listed as response and recovery or
preparedness and protection but the
document says mission impact is
minimized as FEMA will curtail training
travel and public engagement the 40 page
report also says that without the
transfer of funds ice will not be able
to fulfill its adult detention
requirements this year in their response
a spokesman for the Department of
Homeland Security said the funds cut
from FEMA war from routine operating
expenses and could not have been used
for hurricane response DHS also says
that under no circumstances was any
disaster relief funding transferred from
FEMA to ice services Nora
alright Jeff thank you so much